we're pleased to have on the program
once again a very busy man so
we're appreciative of the minutes that
we're about to get with the chief
medical officer of the national football
league dr
alan sills how are you dr sills hey i'm
doing great rich how are you doing
i'm better for talking to you and
greatly appreciative of the time i know
you've got a lot going on and a lot
updating going on so um look i'm not
going to ask you about what you
what you thought about the tennessee
titans and the reports about them
practicing
there's an investigative arm for that in
the nfl what does the fact that a team
tests negative for two straight days
after testing
positive on mass or a large amount doing
it and then there's more tests
of positive after that what did the
tests tell you about what might have
happened in tennessee
dr sills well i think anytime you have a
positive test rich you're always trying
to understand
what transmission might have occurred
where there might be exposures and where
there could be ongoing transmission and
we know that any time somebody's exposed
to covid
it's not as if you become infected
immediately or maybe i should say more
importantly do you become infectious to
others
there's an incubation period where the
virus lives and starts to replicate in
the in the new person
and then at some point that person will
test positive
they may or may not develop symptoms as
we know not everybody develops symptoms
and then of course as their viral load
continues to increase they can actually
shed virus and become infectious to
others so
anytime you have a positive case and
certainly when you have multiple
positive cases
you're trying to look to say okay when
my transmission have occurred what do
these individuals have in common
when were they around each other when
were they exposed and so i think that
that's why it's been so crucial to get
to the most accurate information
possible to try to determine when those
exposures might have occurred because
you don't let everybody get back
together if you're concerned that
they're still ongoing transmission or
infected individuals so
i guess again just connecting dots if a
team is told to stay away
and then there's reports that they've
actually had some unauthorized practices
and they test positive
uh after being told to stay away that
would set off an alarm bell just from
the testing front
well we know as you said that there's a
lag time between when you're exposed um
to the virus and then when you'll test
positive and then when
we get those results and and we go back
and and try to put those pieces together
so
um it's an evolving story and it's one
where we know that also that once you're
exposed
you may test positive at varying times
not everybody test positive let's say
day two or day four
it can be up to seven eight nine days
before someone
is uh is testing positive most people we
think
at present again when i say we not the
nfl the broader medical community
yes we think most people after they're
exposed probably are going to be
infected enough to turn positive on a
sensitive test somewhere in two to five
days but it can be a lot longer than
that and we've seen that happen
so uh when when we find and and this is
one of the many reasons why i wanted to
have you on
is so many fans when they heard about
stefan gilmore testing positive
after the chiefs and patriots played a
game
that it's possible is it possible when
that happens that he
wasn't infectious on the field or does
that mean he was
infectious on the field if he tests
positive so close
to testing negative and playing with a
negative test
yeah it's a great question it's one
where we have to say we just don't know
the answer definitively but it is
certainly possible and here's why
again i refer back to the fact that
these tests that we're doing they're
incredibly sensitive
which means they pick up very very very
low levels of virus in the body
so you know anytime you have a virus
it's going to start replicating you're
going to get more and more and more
copies
and you have to get to a certain number
of copies in the virus to become
infectious to others where you can
spread it to others
but our tests we believe will actually
pick that virus up even prior to that
when there's still these very low levels
now again no one knows exactly the
timeline on those
so i would just say you never want to
assume that someone was not infected
uh or infectious to others but certainly
with the sensitivity of our tests
you know if someone tests negative on a
morning
are they infectious later that day you
know the likelihood is low but certainly
not zero now i was talking albert breer
of sports illustrated
in the first hour dr sills and he said
that he you know
when when the concept of when the
patriots were going to play after cam
tested positive was based on a series of
factors including looking at
videos of inside the facility and
matching it up with the number of times
cam was uh close to someone else outside
of the facility based on inside the
facility and matching it with videos of
him being masked up
can you walk me through the process of
how you and the rest of the medical team
goes about the concept of when you
decide
when somebody tests positive if a game
should be played or not
can you walk me through all that sure so
anytime as i said that you have a
positive
test you're going to look at the close
contacts that may
have been exposed to that individual
when they were positive so if someone
tests positive on a certain day
we typically go back 48 or 72 hours and
we look at
were there close contacts and close
contact information is gathered from
several sources
one is these kinexon tracking devices
that everyone wears
so we we know that everybody has those
on and we can look at who was around who
and for what length of time and so we
clearly have parameters set up again
using general public health guidelines
about distance of time
and so that's one source of information
but you also want to look at
other other sources of contact and and
whether or not those fall into what i
would call a high risk
category because you know rich if you
and i are standing outside somewhere
and let's say we're five and a half feet
apart or five feet ten inches apart
and we're both wearing a mask you know
our risk to each other in that situation
is probably relatively low we're out of
doors there's a lot of air movement we
both got a mask on
you know we're at a pretty close
approximation to six feet distance
but we could be inside together let's
say eight feet apart
but in a fairly small room and maybe
we're eating a meal together and we're
not
masked and that could be a higher risk
exposure for us
so it points out the fact that not every
contact is the same and you have to look
at each case individually so as we look
at an exposure like you mentioned
we've got one player testing positive we
try to look at the tracking data of
course first and foremost
but we also want to look at the any
close contact that might have occurred
beyond that and then lastly when you
mention video what we're trying to get
there is an assessment of how
how likely is everyone to have been
exposed just uh
in the day-to-day operations of the club
and so
getting some assessment of whether
people are wearing masks and whether
they're being compliant with the
protocols as best we can tell
that was an important part of that
decision making so you basically take
all of those factors together and then
you've got additional testing
because again if someone else were
exposed prior to that and this is coming
into that same wave of infection you
would hope to pick that up in the first
several days as well so
that's kind of all of the information
you take and when i say you take it's
not just the nfl again we have a panel
of
expert infectious disease doctors
epidemiologists and all of us looked at
that data and said when do we think it
would be safe to play a game
the last part of that i can tell you
rich that what didn't enter that
calculation what nobody talked about is
well what is the tv schedule or what
about our you know
uh competitive standings or this and
that you know the the football part of
it if you will did not enter into the
discussions about when it might be safe
to play
dr alan sills nfl's chief medical
officer here on the rich eisen show
and the schedule i mean you know we as
fans that's that's what we're focused on
clearly while you're doing the hard work
we're just focusing on when we can go
back down the rabbit hole of not
worrying about it right
so no i'm serious we'd all like to get
to that point where we don't have to
worry about this but unfortunately we
don't think that's going to be soon and
and in the meantime our challenge is the
same we said through outreach which is
how do we learn to live with this virus
how can we protect ourselves mitigate
risk
still try to have some semblance of our
normal activity and and yet stay safe
no i i know that the reason why that's
for all of us i know the reason why i
did bring it up
um in that manner is because this is
what we're focused on
as fans and when we hear about what was
going on with the titans
and we knew that game was um pushed
to week seven then we hear one of the
stars of the game tests positive
and then this the streams do get crossed
on a monday night but we didn't know
that sunday morning after
which we heard about a saints player
might be positive he wasn't
so much conversation from many people
saying league should just stop
should just stop for a week or two weeks
or bubble up
is that on the table when you have these
conversations
dr sills well everything's always on the
table rich we've always said we're
open-minded to whatever it takes to keep
everyone safe and so
you certainly don't want to rule out any
potential option
i just would say that you have to look
at the totality of the experience and
the risks that are involved
and and what the risk of transmission is
and we've been at this now about 10
weeks we've had over
really close to half a million tests now
you know we've had about 84
players and staff test positive over
those 10 weeks
and in the overwhelming majority of
those cases you know if
there has not been transmission in the
in the team meaning we had one single
case that happened over 60 times rich
where we had one person test positive
player or coach and there wasn't
transmission in the team
now we don't want to get comfortable
with that and we certainly don't want to
say
uh look at us while we're leading the
pack here
what we have to say is that our
protocols have have been very effective
in most cases
obviously now we've had an outbreak on
one team and we've got a second team of
concern
but but the point is we have to look at
each case individually
and look and see what we're able to
accomplish and i think
all these protocols are only as good as
the compliance i mean we can have it
sort of like a game plan risk you can
have the best game plan in the world
if we don't go out and execute it well
we know it doesn't turn out well
and kind of to stay in that football
analogy mode you can have 10 guys on a
play doing their job if one person's not
the play falls apart so so all that to
say that we
we're we're very vulnerable when we when
we're not at 100
on our protocols we've said that 90 or
95
is a failing grade here we just that
leaves too much opening for this virus
to get in
so what you just said leads me to my
final two questions with you then uh
first things first is obviously you
would be the one to help set the
protocols up for a bubble
if it is there a plan like in a top
right hand drawer somewhere because it
would require
a ton of moving parts and union
league so much more is there a bubble
plan somewhere in somebody's top right
hand drawer to pull out if necessary
you find it necessary well we've
discussed bubble scenarios all the way
back into the summer when we in the
union together looked at that i i think
i would just tell you a couple of things
about a bubble there's no absolute
bubble you've always got people coming
in and out not players and coaches but
you know service workers support workers
and things like that and that can
introduce the virus
and being in a bubble does not change
the basic need for all the other parts
of the protocol
if you're in a bubble you still must do
mask you still must do distance you
still must do hand hygiene you still
have to change all of these things so
it doesn't change anything on our
day-to-day operations the other thing i
think you have to consider there though
rich is not just the infectious disease
but what's the mental health and the
emotional behavioral health toll inside
a bubble
when you're asking people to leave their
families and isolate themselves for
months at a time
that's a substantial challenge for
michelin behavioral health
and i think that's something that
doesn't always get discussed but i think
it's an important part of the
calculation so you're always looking at
what can you gain
and versus what is the what is the
downside so i would just say we have all
those discussions we continue to
evaluate
but our focus right now is is on the
protocols which largely have been
working
and trying to make sure we're all
following them as carefully as we can
and then the last thing that you
mentioned that you know
in a team he takes all 11 right to
matriculate a ball down the field or all
11 to stop
a team from doing that and you know if
one person doesn't do the job then
that's a problem
uh you know not to call anybody out but
in the two minutes that we have left
here
obviously the tennessee titans um um
something's up there
uh we saw a handful of raiders while
they were trying to do some good
uh for a charity uh went out um
we've seen some coaches get slapped down
considerably uh
because they're not massed up what do
you say to anybody in the nfl community
that still needs
a message on this front dr alan sills
well we've said that it takes all of us
and and i think maybe coach tomlin i
heard him quoted yesterday who said when
one person fails we all fail we're all
in this together but we also say this is
hard i mean this is really hard this is
a relentless opponent
and as i said before this virus only
needs a small opening and i think
everyone has the best of intention
everyone wants to stay safe everyone
wants to keep their
their fellow team members and everyone
in the environment safe
but it just takes that day after day
sustained effort and as a doctor i know
you know rich there plenty of times that
i give advice to patients and tell them
here's the right thing to do here's what
you need to do it's just hard to follow
that all the time we all recognize that
so
i think we have to give some grace to
people to say this is really hard it's
difficult to do it all the time
but really the only chance we have to
stay safe as i said is to aim for that
100
compliance to keep ourselves safe and to
keep our team environment safe and so
we're going to continue to focus on
tools
that will help us do that i know that
the players coaches and staff are very
committed
and we're in this together this isn't
about us uh being on opposite sides
we have one common opponent here and
that's this virus and that's uniting the
entire nfl at this time
all right thank you for the call dr
sills greatly appreciate it and uh keep
doing what you're doing
and i'd love to have you back on as
conditions warrant
thank you thank you happy to do that
rich have a great day you bet that's dr
alan sills the chief medical officer
of the national football league